[Music]
The Breakfast Club made stars out of its
young cast including Judd Nelson as
criminal and resident bad boy John
bender since his brat pack days Nelson
has been keeping plenty busy with film
and television appearances here's what
he's been up to throughout the years
many audiences might think that Nelson's
first film appearance was in The
Breakfast Club but it wasn't he appeared
in three films before The Breakfast Club
Rock & Roll Hotel making the great and
Fandango Rock & Roll Hotel has largely
been lost a time but some 80s movie
goers may recognize Nelson from the
second two titles in 1984 is making the
grade
Nelson played a small-time con artist
who must impersonate a rich prep school
kid to earn $10,000 in 1985 spent dango
he played a nerdy member of a group of
college friends who takes one last trip
before graduation cast also included a
young Kevin Costner in his first
starring role the film however failed at
the box office
though Nelson had yet to find much
success in the film world both making
the grade and Fandango set him up
perfectly for his next project Judd
Nelson's big breakthrough came in 1985
with writer director John Hughes The
Breakfast Club the cast included Molly
Ringwald Ally Sheedy Anthony Michael
Hall Emilio Estevez and Nelson as high
school students stuck in saturday
detention it's really not even close by
good you got one more right there The
Breakfast Club was a smash hit making
instant stars out of each of the five
main actors including Nelson later that
year he rejoined many of his cast
members in Joel Schumacher's st. Elmo's
fire that film about recent Georgetown
University graduates added to me more
and Rob Lowe to the cast that also
included Sheedy & Estevez the stars of
these films became so immediately
notorious that a New York magazine
reporter coined the term the brat pack
after seeing some of the young actors
get mobbed in public none of the actors
including Nelson liked the label but the
term inspired by Sinatra's Rat Pack
stuck for years to come and remains
associated with many of them today even
though Nelson never officially returned
to the brat pack throughout his next
series of film and television
appearances he would occasionally
night with some of his former co-stars
in 1986 Nelson lent his voice as hot rod
and Rodimus Prime to the cartoon
Transformers the movie which has since
become a cult classic despite a poor
box-office performance after retaining
with fellow brat Packer Ally Sheedy in
the 1986 revenge drama blue city Nelson
took a different approach by appearing
in the universally praised dear America
letters home from Vietnam a documentary
where actors read correspondences from
the war he then starred in the two-part
NBC TV movie billionaire boys club which
earned Nelson a Golden Globe nomination
for his leading role ultimately he
finished out the 1980s with a few other
film appearances including the roadtrip
film never on Tuesday which also
featured Emilio Estevez Nelson stayed
quite busy throughout the 1990s thanks
to a long stretch of film and television
work after working with famed actor Max
von Sydow in the world war ii inspired
hiroshima out of the ashes he played the
worst comedian in recorded history
in the dark backward following that he
appeared in Mario Van Peebles 1991
gangster film New Jack city
which co-starred rapper turned actor
ice-t as ice tea's partner on a police
investigation Nelson found both
commercial and critical success 1994
gave Nelson a chance to flex his comedy
chops alongside a young Adam Sandler in
airheads the film received mostly
negative reviews from critics but has
since gained cult following in some
circles close out the 90s Nelson
returned to the gangster genre with the
1990 film lighted up appearing as a high
school history teacher who helps
troubled teens during the 1990s Nelson
took a bit of a breather from his film
work to take a starring role in the hit
sitcom suddenly Susan premiering in
September of 1996 suddenly Susan starred
Brooke Shields as a newly single
magazine writer Nelson played the role
of Susan's boss Jack Richmond moving
away from his 80s bad-boy image Nelson
got the stretch his acting muscles as
Jack by building on story arcs involving
his character's troubled marriage
suddenly Susan was a ratings hit in its
first season but lost viewers by season
two and never fully recovered
Nelson left the show at the beginning of
season 4
throughout the 2000s Nelson appeared in
a number of recurring stints on
television shows including spots on both
CSI and CSI in New York Las Vegas the
Outer Limits and the detective comedy
psych he also snagged a recurring guest
role as a comically jealous ex-husband
on the eighth season of Two and a Half
Men coincidentally Nelson appeared
alongside Charlie Sheen on the series
the brother of his fellow brat Packer
Emilio Estevez thanks to his signature
role as John bender Nelson was also able
to snag some roles in the beginning of
the 21st century in addition to making a
significant cameo in Jay and Silent Bob
strike back nelson revived the bender
character for an uncredited role in the
Star Wars themed Family Guy episode blue
harvest any questions yeah I got a
question does Barry Manilow know you
raid his wardrobe throughout the 2000s
and 2010's Nelson kept up his career in
both film and television mixing
made-for-tv movies with Studio
productions and animated shows he
returned to the Transformers franchise
in 2009 playing Rodimus Prime for the
Cartoon Network series while also
voicing multiple roles for the animated
series Ben 10 omniverse Nelson has also
dabbled in hallmark films including
Santa Junior in 2002 and 2010's canceled
Christmas in the latter film he plays
Chris Frost who is of course secretly
Santa Claus
in 2009 he appeared in the sequel The
Boondock Saints to All Saints Day much
like its predecessor however the sequel
is met with negative reviews Nelson's
biggest starring role in the 2000s was
the television movie cabin by the lake
it aired on the USA Network in 2000 and
starred Nelson as a screenwriter who
moonlights as a serial killer the
following year he starred in a sequel
return to cabin by the lake though
neither film fared particularly well
with critics in recent years Nelson has
sought out new and challenging roles and
some of televisions most interesting
shows in 2013 during the fourth and
final season of Nikita
Nelson played a deep-cover operative
unknowingly working for the terrorist
organization known as the shop Nelson
later took a role on the hugely popular
hip hop drama Empire in the show's
wildly
successful first season Nelson played a
cutthroat and competitive CEO named
Billy beretti thanks to the show's major
success Nelson found himself back in the
spotlight and with a great new credit to
boot check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite actors are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belt so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]